a guy who was just getting started 18
years ago who had one super bowl and who
was a year away from getting his next
two
tom brady at age 43
we played the clip on the way in he said
he will definitely consider playing past
the age of 45 if he keeps playing the
way that he is now this is something we
talked about last week i mean look he's
always used that expiration date that
seems far enough out into the future
that never has to talk about it used to
say i'm playing 10 more years the next
year i'm playing 10 more years the next
year i'm playing 10 more years then he
started saying until he's 45. now that
45 is two seasons away and he's playing
pretty damn well why would he stop i
think this guy will go as long as he can
he'll take it to 50 if he can make it
he'll take it beyond 50 if he can make
it shireen
we've never seen anything like it mike
you know you started seeing
peyton manning that the legs give way as
you've always talked about the legs go
first we saw that with peyton his last
year he couldn't have gone another year
but with tom brady you don't see that i
mean you look at the yards that he
passed for it's incredible he's almost
passed for 5500 yards this season
counting the postseason it's been
amazing that's the fourth most of his
career the arm has gone nowhere the legs
looked pretty good he only took 21 sacks
this season only one time in the last 11
years has he taken fewer he thanked this
offensive lineman he said today on the
call with uh some watches that just came
in from europe some expensive watches so
he appreciates that offensive line mike
but this is a guy who doesn't look like
he's toward the end he does look like
he's in the midst of his career the the
the prime of his career and i just don't
see him
retiring until we know that it's the end
and he said he'll know when it's in it's
not the end yet i just don't think we've
seen that it's amazing to watch
what he's doing at this age mike
unbelievable
the the
giving of watches is fitting because
father time ultimately will dictate when
tom brady has to step aside and father
time as al michaels said three years ago
during the super bowl 52 broadcast
father time doesn't know where tom brady
lives tom brady has defied father time
to the point where that becomes
the
identifying feature of his career and
it's the longer he goes
the more he wants to go to make a
extremely timely and hip reference it
reminds me of the seinfeld episode when
cramer is test driving the new sub and
they're getting close to empty and he
just wants to push it as far as he can
how far can tom brady take this car that
has a tank that inevitably will be out
of gas who knows 46 47 50 who knows but
the way he played this year and the way
that he's been embraced by tampa in a
season that had not nearly as many fans
as hopefully will be present for next
year's games there's a lot of money to
be made by the buccaneers if they can
keep this guy around and there's more
championships to win you know he's in
super bowl number 10 it would be stupid
to just say well this is the last one
with tom brady you can never say
anything is the last one shireen
i think he's been rejuvenated too mike
when you look at going to a new place
where it's warm his family has seemed to
embrace tampa he's embraced learning a
new offense and being around bruce
aryans and you know i think that was a
relationship that had to evolve and i
think it has to evolve to a point now
where they know the the other very very
well and i think they're enjoying uh
this relationship that's obviously going
to extend to next year and i think he's
enjoying being with byron leftwich and
his teammates so i i think this has been
very good for tom brady to leave and go
elsewhere we don't always see these type
of things working out when you think of
emmitt smith even joe montana didn't win
a super boy to get to the playoffs but
didn't want a super bowl there but a ton
of these have just not worked out quite
the way that they had hoped peyton
manning and tom brady obviously have
worked out in their second careers at
different places
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports